Film Courage: How is finding work in Los Angeles
as a director different from other places?
Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker: That's a good
question. I've lived quite a few different
places around the country. I just grew up in
Portland, Oregon. I lived in Nashville for many
years. I lived in Eastern Washington. I lived back
in Portland and attended to LA. Every single city
in the country has their own little interesting
(if you do film) it has their own little
interesting hub. For the most part most cities
have some sort of industry that keeps it going.
In Portland and Seattle there's Microsoft and Nike
and Adidas excuse me a bunch of ad agencies there
so the for the most part a
lot of the work that people do
is in that realm so I mean you can have a
great career just doing Microsoft videos
and there's no shame in that and that's sort
of the industry that it's going to be and
the only difference between that and like in
Nashville is replace Microsoft with music videos
it's the same kind of thing probably a
smaller more tight-knit film community
doing similar kind of stuff and also great careers
can be had by doing that I've recently been doing
a lot of work in Florida and Tampa and there
their industry is HGTV I believe yeah it's
based there so they a lot of the people that work
there work there at doing and then I think Ashley
Furniture makes a lot of their commercials there
so almost everyone I've worked with usually has
spent some time working in that little realm so
moving from city to city that's not a hub city.
That's the biggest difference it's really
just okay what industry is here and then
now if you're talking indie film the indie
film markets in those towns look identical
which is kind of funny and there's almost
this funny little divide between those who are
doing the corporate work like doing the Microsoft
stuff or the ad agency world and then there's the
Indie filmmakers over here and usually those two
worlds don't intersect that much in a weird way
now I think there's a middle step as well and that
would be the Hub cities cities like New Orleans
and Atlanta and New Mexico so in those cities
tons and tons of work is happening if you are
below the line any kind of crew position makeup
artist and whatever gaffer, grips, ACS all of that
stuff you will work you can work as much as you
want and you're working on great big stuff you're
probably going to be able to really do quite well
and that is a if you want to work in movies and
even if you do want to be a director but
you're still you're starting out and you're
working your way up the ladder those could be
a great cities to go to because it's it's like
I can I have a friend who just moved to New
Orleans a few years ago and he told me when
he first moved there he couldn't believe how
much work was actually happening they were
doing a big movie and their base camp where all
the catering was where you met in the morning
was actually shared by two other gigantic
productions three of them sharing one huge
base camp like that's insane I can't even imagine
that and he said that this boy if you live here
you could work as much as you want full-time
year-round full union rates all of it like
you could just clean house and work
and work and work and work work
so that does exist in LA but it's a lot
harder to to get because everybody moves to LA
to pursue film so everybody's a filmmaker you're
if you came from Kansas City and you were really
good at and you had that corner of the market
on the whatever's in Kansas City you are really
nothing special when you get to LA like there will
be it's not that you're not talented it's just
that everybody does that here like everybody's
like that LA is those of you who don't live here
like the biggest difference is that LA is where
the decisions happen so if you are above the line
writers directors mainly and actors who want
to be on larger things you got to be here
so getting on those projects in an above the line
position is a whole different game than anything
else that you have to worry about in other cities
all you got to do in say a Portland to get work is
you're probably going to bid on it by against a
couple of production houses that you're probably
friends with you're going to hire them anyway once
you get the job so it doesn't matter but you're
probably baiting on it in some sort of way then
the budgets are not going to yeah they may be all
right but they're not going to be Millions more
than likely and yeah it's going to be a little
a fun little corporate thing and it's going to be
lower pressure I mean high pressure for the client
but overall the grand scope of life not that
big of a deal LA it's 100 different than that
you can work here and most people do
when they get here if you're trying to
get here and work as a filmmaker yes there
is work to be had is it work that you want
that's the question that's the real trick
because most of the people that he move here
well you got to work somewhere and It generally
will come down to do I work waiting tables
or do I work anywhere I can get into the
industry and that might be an assistant to
some writer you're not you're not writing anything
but you're their assistant getting their coffee it
might be most of the people I know go into reality
somewhere some way is it the dream job absolutely
not do they like it probably not for the most
part but that's there's a lot of that kind of work
below the line stuff you might be running a camera
you might be producing but it's is not the dream
job at all so it's a weird almost like purgatory
that exists here because this is giant machine
and that's the best way to define it LA is an
industry most of these other towns are communities
that's a huge Gulf of a difference so when you're
here you get you can get stuck in this filmmaker
purgatory of like constantly working on stuff
you don't like like reality shows or whatever
and then you're you're making some money and
you're surviving but you cannot figure out how
to cross the threshold from that to all right I'm
going to hire you because you're a great director
to direct on this television show or Helm the next
Marvel film like that's a that's a much weirder
barrier to cross and that doesn't exist and if
you don't live here you're probably not going to
have to deal with that unless you're incredibly
lucky unless you just happen to be the one guy
who won that lottery ticket and gets discovered
by the president of Disney and brings you over
otherwise forget it it's probably not going
to happen so that's a real trick a real weird
most filmmakers you meet in LA are in purgatory
they're not weird they're they're all writing
something they're all developing something they're
all all of us everyone I know they have the thing
they want to do they have no idea how to get
over that bridge but they all want to do it
I think if you're going to move
here that is an important thing
to understand because you've got to
work somewhere you got to make a living
and I think if you understand going in that
your life will probably be taken over by
that purgatory you have to continue then
to keep working on your own craft when
you're not on set doing this other thing
over here that is the key to figuring
it out is I've I have got to live I
have got to make a living somewhere
putting a barrier around that and going when I'm
not doing that then I'm going to work on my thing
every writer I know who's got an agent they their
agents always tell them or managers tell them the
same thing yeah I know you're working all day on
that TV show and I know you're tired but if you
want anything if you want to have a career of your
own at all you have to keep working on your own
stuff on the side they tell them that straight
up and every writer I know does that they'll
work all day on their thing when they get home
they eat their dinner they sit in there and they
write for a couple hours on their own passion
projects and that is how they break through
that is how they keep going forward it's harder
especially when you get married you start having
kids life starts getting in the way and they find
the energy to do that is is the biggest challenge
that leads me to my next question because we
have a quote from you that we got from our
2019 interview that we did with you what you do in
the dark when no one is looking that's where your
medal is that's how you get better do you still
Embrace this idea yeah no question about it I
yes it is when you're in your when you're young
when you're in your teens in your 20s we are all
going to school right we and then when we get
out of college most of us stop why is that why
do we all stop learning and taking classes and
honing why do we do that what is there is there
like did somebody on high like flick a switch and
say you've learned all that you need to know no no
but we seem to always do that
and the only way to do that is
the self discipline to continue on your
own when no one's looking all right
now not on Facebook what can I learn
what am I lacking in my directing skills
gee I really suck at working with actors I should
probably get better at that how do I do that well
maybe read a couple of books or take that's that's
where the real yes you you must do that if you
want to be the best you have to do that I was I
was working on a show recently in this last year
and in the last couple of years
I was in a writing class and
I started the writing class because
I just wanted to get better at
crafting stories it just understanding how
storytelling works on the most basic level
um it was an area that I felt was
lacking in my own journey and so
I yeah I'm going to I'm going to do this so
at night I was taking this class landed this
job and I'm directing all these episodes
and the executive producer pulls me aside
and he says because there's been a few people
that have come up to me and say and and said to me
why is the guy who's directing your
show taking a writing class at night
and he said to me he goes and they're telling me
this they're asking me this like it's a negative
and I said to them are you crazy it's because
he knows that life's a journey that you have to
keep sharpening and honing and pushing all the
time otherwise you stagnate is that he thinks
that's why he's got the job because he knows
that not because he goes ah I know everything
it was such an interesting thing to hear but that
that's an insight into how most of us think like
we get to a point where we think we've mastered
it and if you think that you probably haven't
and do you think that that goes back to what
we talked about sort of I guess a snobbery
in this business because at what point has
anybody finished with learning something yeah
I think I can I think I think a lot of the the
traditional snobbery that we think of when we
think of Hollywood I mean I think ultimately
stems from insecurity this idea that maybe
I'm not if they were to be honest in the dark
maybe I'm not as good as I think I am Maybe
I mean a lot of the people that have treated
me poorly were people that were threatened but
I mean I'm not saying I'm all that I'm just
saying all of us have experienced that where
you just there's someone that you run into that
treats you badly and you almost know on this gut
level that it's like I think they're threatened
by me I don't even know why I'm not trying to
like hurt them I'm not trying to beat them but
they are viewing me like I'm trying to be like
so it all stems from this deep deep insecurity
I think that's really a shame and a lot of the
people I think who are the worst offenders of
that are the people that don't continue to grow
they feel like this is where you'll
hear it too you'll hear it when it when
someone will complain about the young coming
up and taking their jobs that's where you can
really spot it that is someone who has it's a
it's a growth mindset versus a fixed mindset
it's a fixed mindset is someone who believes
that talent is something you're born with
a growth mindset is some someone that believes
that Talent is something that can be learned
by continuing repeated Behavior now you may have
a knack a propensity for math or photography but
that doesn't mean you're a genius out of the womb
it has to be cultivated and worked the people that
use those terms like those kids don't know what
they're doing they don't want to hire an expert
well no it's not that it's probably not that at
all it's because they're hungry they're they're
coming up and and fighting for it to learn and
they're probably they're the ones watching film
courage interviews to get better the people that
are angry are not they're not they're just not
now they're all going to comment on on this
one and say what is that kind of but it's
yeah that's I think that's where
that comes from though I that
and I think if you are one of those people
and you're constantly feeling this threat
it's time to take a serious look at where you
are standing and where those feelings are really
coming from are you feeling threatened
because you're worried about your job
and if you're worried about your job why
are you so worried is it because you think
that they're going to discover you for
being a fraud maybe or is it because
I don't know like there's many
reasons why that could be I just think
it's time for self-reflection time so
you can find yourself in that position I
think we can all think back to when we were
threatened of someone I mean I can picture
being 14 and being incredibly threatened
of somebody and now that I look back on it
it was because yeah I was afraid they were going
to was my little part-time job and then I thought
they were going to take my job and they weren't
they were just there for the summer yeah before
they went to college but it's if we look back
to things when when we did it to we can say okay
well that was why I couldn't say hi to this
and then and then when it happens to you in
reverse then you go okay that's a fair point it
is a fair point because yes I've struggled with
that too there's certainly directors have
come up that I'm like frustrated with like
but if I'm being honest I would say it's because
I could even I mean it's been it's happened I'll
see some 20 year old do something that I can't do
that bothers me because whatever and it's who
knows they spent all their high school years we're
learning After Effects and they just got really
good at doing VFX and they're coming out of the
gate with some amazing short it's like how in the
world did he and I feel threatened by that and I
want to treat them badly because of that I think
it's just that's not instead wouldn't it be better
and I'm talking to myself here but wouldn't it be
better for me to take a look at this person and go
maybe we should team up wouldn't it be cool to
like take someone who's got that desire and has
the skill that I struggle with and to bring them
on to my team and we can work together I mean this
is a collaborative art after all should isn't that
the way it's supposed to work like you're taking
all these artists who are hungry do how much
that would mean to him or her if you did that
and how hard they would work because chances are
they are looking at you as a veteran or whatever
wanting that approval and and just begging for
a shot I think it would be a much healthier way
of looking at it because think about it that's
what we all want that's what we all wanted we
all want someone to believe in us and not
be threatened by us and give us a shot so
and it actually makes me wonder if the those
of us who feel threatened who feel angry who
who if we feel like well no one ever helped
me why should I help them or maybe I don't
have anything to give them because I never did
get a shot so they're going to just surpass me
those are all hard questions to
to process I think if you recognize
that that's how you're feeling
it's time for reality check on maybe maybe you
have gotten shots and maybe you are further than
you think maybe you are someone of influence
that does have a lot to give and holding on so
tightly to your position is is I think it's like
a cancer because it because when you do that this
gets back to what we were talking about originally
holding on to something when it's trying life is
trying to slip past and morph it in your hands
maybe it could grow into something even more
incredible than you you're imagining right now
like whenever you start to feel that gut go yep
and hold on to that thing like I think that's a
time to like take a serious look at where you are.